I am shocked and incensed,
and rightfully so.
I've spent the last four months in a hell with some called pregnancy
while I have been bedridden and too sick to care for myself.
Too sick to take a shower or get my own food,
if I can even eat. I've had to rely on the care of others
while I lay helpless on the couch
day after day, unable to leave my home.
I've had nurses come to my house repeatedly
to give me IVs for dehydration
caused by days of non stop vomiting
after struggling with chronic illness and then struggling to conceive.
I've experienced trial in my life,
but this pregnancy is the hardest thing I have ever been through.
Why am I incensed? I have been met with ableism,
derision, and condescension,
and I have realized through this experience
why so many women feel alone in motherhood.
Because from the minute you get pregnant,
and even before you are met with the insensitive opinions of others.
I've been told to just get a hobby and I'll forget about the nausea.
I've been told if I struggle with pregnancy,
then I don't know how you're gonna be a mom.
I have been told that I am lazy,
entitled, ungrateful,
taking advantage of my husband,
and insensitive to those experiencing infertility
because apparently
you can't struggle with both infertility and pregnancy.
I am not saying all this to complain about internet trolls,
but instead
to validate every woman who Feels guilty for struggling in pregnancy
because at the end of the day,
no matter how much you want that baby,
your struggle is still valid.
It is not insensitive to share your journey.
You deserve care and compassion.
We all have the ability to lift people up and tear them down.
I can't control my symptoms,
but I can control how I use my experience,
and that will be to make other women feel seen,
and not alone for struggling.